as if things weren't a tinderbox already
fox news propagandist tucker carlson is
now suggesting
a real insurrection on his program now
the term real insurrection is of course
tucker playing coy
with the january 6 trump riots tucker
and others
claim that january 6 was not really an
insurrection and when they say that it's
never totally clear if they mean
it's not really an insurrection because
it failed or
it's not an insurrection because it
wasn't really meant to be
an insurrection in any case we've talked
before about stochastic terrorism and
this idea that with a large enough
audience
even subtly if you put an idea into
people's minds
someone becomes likely to go and
actually do the thing
uh if you subtly put the idea in an
audience of a hundred people to go and
kill someone
um it's not super likely that someone's
really going to do it but if your
audience is a thousand or ten thousand
or a million
or ten million once it gets to be a
large audience
that subtle idea becomes more and more
likely to actually influence someone in
the crowd to do and
go and do the thing you're subtly
suggesting they do in this clip
tucker's not even floating the idea
subtly he's just saying
why don't we have a real insurrection
and why does he want one
well because of misstatements that his
guest
the mayor of uvalde texas don mclaughlin
tells about immigration these are lies
about immigration and it makes tucker
say
what about a real insurrection over this
take a look that the people coming north
from
latin america central america a lot of
cases are aware that there's a new
administration the united states and the
policies are different
oh most definitely they're telegraphing
it down there uh
what do you when you see t-shirts with
people say buy them let me in
biden let me and they're all over i mean
you know it's telegraphed back down
there one of them comes over and they'll
tell you
as soon as i get over and get through
i'm calling back home and i'm selling 10
more to come
that i got in come on we're sending a
message that hey
the border's open come on in do what you
want i mean
why aren't we enforcing the laws that
are on the book that are already on the
book that says
you can't cross that border illegally or
whatever but yet we're going to reward
you with
putting you in a nice hotel or or give
you a 1400 visa card debit card that you
can use
while you're here in the states you know
until you get established or whatever
and how many times they replenish what
do you mean give a 14 visa debit card
i'm
i i haven't been able to confirm this
yet but i have been told that they're
giving you
these immigrant families they're in
these hotels they're giving them a 14
i mean a 1400 visa card why don't we
have a real insurrection
at some point like why why would we put
up with this well
in my opinion you're closer than you've
ever been in our country of getting to
that
i think we're closer i feel closer to
that i mean this is absolutely
it's it's beyond insulting it's in it's
oppressing the population
so there's a lot there now before we get
into the really crazy part from tucker
don mclaughlin there the mayor of uvalde
texas said
illegal aliens are getting 1400 bucks
this is related to the stimulus package
that the number 1400 is not a
coincidence 1400 was
what was in the biden stimulus package
the claim they make is
uh undocumented immigrants are getting
1400
stimulus checks it's not true if an
immigrant is here illegally
they won't have a social security number
which you need to have in order to get a
stimulus check
biden's covet 19 relief package excludes
most immigrants who are not in the
united states legally from getting
stimulus checks
the relief packages during the trump era
did the same thing it's the same
there's no difference only non-citizens
who are here authorized to work
who can get a social security number can
get the stimulus
however according to some in the
associated press
some people who entered the u.s on valid
temporary working visas
which makes them eligible for a social
if they overstayed
they might accidentally get a for the
1400
this is a tiny number of people and it's
a distraction
and the idea that just any old and
undocumented immigrant is getting 1400
is completely wrong it's been widely
debunked but let's get to the really
wacky part this
real insurrection that tucker carlson
wants this is very dangerous
now i am very close to a free speech
absolutist and what i mean by that is i
believe any speech that is not actually
illegal is legal and thus should be
allowed period
is that legal that's a call for violence
it's a real call for violence it's a
clear call for violence
it's not subtle it's not using coded
language
this type of thing is the actually
illiberal anti-democratic authoritarian
threat that we've been talking about
what immigrants get 1400 uh
i don't even know if that's true but
what about a real insurrection yes let's
do it why not
right and then you go back to those
claims made in court by some of the
trump writers from january 6 fox news
made me do it your honor sir
my client was suffering from foxitis and
foxmania and fox dementia
it's not really their fault and as
outrageous
as we've been saying it is for the party
of personal responsibility to say
that thing i did it was trump and fox's
fault
well no you deserve to be held
accountable
but then when tucker says how about a
real insurrection
you genuinely are starting to muddy it
up
and make it even more complex to
apportion blame and responsibility now
one last thing
if such an insurrection happened thanks
to tucker carlson
tucker carlson's not going to be on the
front lines leading it you understand
that right
tucker will be at his country club or uh
at his v vacation home
tucker is like trump in that they both
value their viewers and supporters
respectively
as far as they are useful to them but
these people the people that voted for
trump
donated to trump rioted for trump on
january 6
the people that watch tucker and would
be likely to do what he says when he
says what about a real insurrection
these are the people that tucker like
trump spent their lives
trying to stay away from and be isolated
from they don't care about those people
beyond their immediate utility either
for ratings
or buying tucker's book has tucker
written a book i don't know or voting
for trump
or donating to trump or whatever the
case may be and in that way tucker and
trump are actually very similar
they're disgusted by their followers
they they have disdain for their
followers
but they understand that these are the
people that ultimately are responsible
for
writing the checks that keep them in
power or whatever the case may be
disgusting stuff and almost as
disgusting as this next thing we're
going to look at
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company
best known for their delicious mushroom
coffee
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies
i've been drinking four sigmatic coffee
a lot lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling
or a midday crash and they have over 20
000 five-star reviews and best of all
if you don't love it you'll get 100
percent of your money back
because they stand behind their product
you've got nothing to lose by giving it
a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic dot com slash pacman the link
is right
underneath this video